Ramadan Mubarak some people say it's a
bid and others say it's a Sunnah what is
your uh ruling on
this to welcome month is good
alhamdulillah and our Prophet always
informed the other people about this
month and as I mentioned earlier that I
beloved Prophet M wasallam it's
mentioned in mus Ahmed R number two page
number
230 Hadith number 7148 which is also
repeated is mentioned in sunai chapter
number five Hadith number 21106 that our
beloved Prophet mallalli wasallam used
to always tell the people when the month
used to approach when it used to come
the prophet to tell the people in
advance oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching
you and Allah subhana wa tala has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month so the prophet used to welcome
this month he used to wish other people
the same way today if he wish as the
prophet said the Blessed month is
approaching if someone says Ramadan
Mubarak this Ramadan Mubarak is more
often said in the Indian
subcontinent by the Indians by the
pakistanis because this word Mubarak
though Bara is an Arabic word Bara means
blessing and it is nothing but blessed
month but when the Indians and
pakistanis when they use the word
Mubarak it is more of a sort of
congratulation when someone passes
examination they sayak in U which you
dve from the Arabic word bar so when
Ramadan comes they wish Ramadan muak
saying that it is the Blessed month or a
sort of
congratulating and wishing each other
that the Blessed month is approaching so
according to me it's not a b you can
welcome the month it's a good thing that
you're calling this month a blessed
month and you're informing other people
reminding them that in this month is a
lot of blessing so according to me it's
not ABA but how you wish the words you
choose that is mubah that's optional
like in Indian subcontinent we use the
word Ramadan Mubarak in the Gulf
countries they Ramadan Kim so all these
words are good the holy month or the
Blessed month or the month of
forgiveness so the choice of words is
yours but the prophet Mall Al wasallam
he used to say to the people that oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching so I feel people should wish
each other and they should remind each
other about blessed month